and China's foreign minister has
reiterated that anything to do with Hong
Kong is an internal matter he's warning
other countries against meddling in its
affairs one gear is still holding a
media briefing in Beijing since the
turbulence over proposed legislative
amendments last June we have seen
increasingly rampant activities by Hong
Kong dependence organizations and
radical localist s-- in Hong Kong
escalating violence and terrorist
activities as well as excessive unlawful
foreign meddling in Hong Kong affairs
others has placed national security in
serious jeopardy and posed a grave
threat to Hong Kong's
prosperity and stability and the
practice of one country two systems'
from all this let's bring in Katrina you
in Beijing Katrina sounds like Beijing
is not in the mood to take any kind of
conciliatory approach on Hong Kong
that's right at the press conference
today 1e is not by doing one bit in fact
he almost expressed some surprise that
people around the world and certainly in
Hong Kong were making such a big deal of
this he was actually saying that the
Hong Kong government and all relevant
parties have voiced support for this
national security law he also said that
Hong Kong is a part of China and it is
the responsibility of the central
government to enact security laws for
the whole country and this is a wide
practice around the world and this is
really just Beijing doing its job he
also said he singled out these
protesters not as the masses not as the
majority of people in Hong Kong but he
called them radical loyalists escalating
violence and even terrorist activities
so very much sidelining them as
extremists and he said that this law
would be good for Hong Kong stability
and people should stop worrying and
basically start looking to the
positivity of Hong Kong's future that
this would not have any negative impact
he said but it would be a good thing for
Hong Kong stability and its position as
an international financial center but as
we heard from Adrienne earlier he's
going to have a quite a hard time
convincing the people in Hong Kong of
that
he also made some comments indicating
Beijing perhaps concerned about tension
with the u.s. at these fragile economic
times right that's right he had a number
of questions about the china-us
relations have been not surprising this
bilateral relationship has been on the
rocks for months and some people have
said that it's in the phase of a new
Cold War and he seems to have agreed he
was saying that China and US are as the
biggest developed country in the biggest
developing country have more to gain
from working together than competing
with each other he also said that China
does not want to change or replace the
US and the US should stop trying to
change China's system and basically the
two should recognize that they both have
different political systems and respect
each other he also said that many in the
US are wanting to smear China and he
spoke specifically of a political virus
that is circulating in China in the US
and he said that US leaders would do
better to use their precious time to
save lives affected by the corona virus
rather than placing the blame on China's
doorstep let's have a listen to what
more he had to say about that
cha-ching it's most regrettable that
while the Karuna virus is still out
there
the political virus is also spreading in
the US and jumping at any opportunity to
attack and slander China some
politicians ignore the basic facts and
make up countless lies and conspiracy
theories concerning China I call on the
US side to stop wasting precious time
and stop costing people's lives it has
come to our attention that some
political forces in the US are taking
china-us relations hostage and pushing
our two countries to the brink of a new
code war there's also a growing drumbeat
internationally of criticism targeting
China because of this pandemic of course
many countries and many leaders are
raising questions as to the origin of
this and questioning whether China is
indeed being transparent about the
origin of carven 19
he also refer answered questions about
this specifically about us politicians
are filing lawsuits against China
sometimes whole States against China
because of this pandemic now one year
had some very strong worth say about
this he said that this was ludicrous he
also said that this these movements or
these lawsuits have no basis in
international law and he continued to
echo some of the words that President Xi
Jinping as mentioned earlier when he
last week during the World Health
Organization summit saying that China
has continued to act responsibility
responsibly continue to be transparent
and the difference between the u.s. some
US politicians in China he said was the
difference in some sense between facts
and lies so also Wang Yi not budging
when it comes to answering questions
trying to call China to account because
of the current a virus indeed all right
let's thank Katrina you there for
updating us on the situation from
Beijing